good morning believe nation today's
message is give it your all over to you
Jeremy Lin it's easy to dream big
there's the initial excitement raw
passion high hopes and you put in
everything you have to pursue your dream
but inevitably the hits will come
you get knocked down you get back up you
get knocked down again
and get back up but the criticism keeps
coming the hard work doesn't seem to be
paying off one unmet expectation after
another please do disappointment
discouragement and even worse doubt
maybe they're right maybe I'll never be
who I thought I would be so what will I
do I'll work harder than I ever have
before
I'll work on my weaknesses and refine my
strengths give more even after I thought
I gave it my all
chances are you gonna quit too soon
chances are you going to stop just as
you're about to make your big
breakthrough chances are you're gonna
regret not saying yes and not continuing
on I told the story a number of times
but the toughest decision I ever had to
make in my life was when I was in
university you had to decide between the
high paying job I thought I always
wanted in my business that was sucking
that I was making $300 a month that and
I couldn't get the momentum that I was
looking for and the easy safe practical
thing to do would have been to take the
job but I felt like I didn't give my all
to my business and I needed to give it a
little bit more time just so that I
wouldn't know just so that I would know
if this thing would work or not and so I
decided to take a year off while some of
my friends are off doing
they'll travelling the world and going
off and exploring I said you know what
I'm gonna take one year and I'm gonna
give everything I have to this business
I'm gonna see if I can make it work and
it may not work and the odds are that
it's not gonna work most businesses
don't work and up until that point
everything that I've done had shown that
my business was not working but I still
felt like it had more gas in the tank I
still felt like even though I gave it a
lot I had not given it my all and I
needed to know I needed to know I could
deal with it not working out and me
walking away knowing that that's it I
gave it everything I had there was
nothing else that I left on the table
that was the best that I could have done
if I did that and it didn't work I'm
good but if I didn't do it if you don't
give it your all if you don't push
yourself to the absolute max and it
doesn't work out you will forever look
back and think
maybe it could have worked that's the
rest of your life that you're dealing
with and I don't want that to be your
story
I don't want you to look back in your
life and regret not having done more not
having pushed harder because that pain
is for the rest of your life that pain
is immense
it's huge versus the short-term pain of
whatever you have to do right now to
give it your all to push a little harder
right to push through those extra hours
to push through those extra sets to push
through that extra work is painful it
sucks but it's nothing compared to the
lifetime of pain and regret that is
ahead of you if you don't give it your
all so if you're on the verge of
quitting something a relationship a
business a partnership a customer if
you're on the verge of quitting
something maybe the answer is to quit
but I would ask yourself am I going to
regret walking away from this did I give
this situation everything I had so I'm
confident that walking away is the right
thing to do it's not just the easy thing
to do it's the right thing to do because
you gave it your all
don't quit too soon don't quit just
before you make your big breakthrough
quit after you giving it here so the
question today today is I'm curious what
percentage out of a hundred words giving
everything you've got a hundred percent
out of that where do you fall what are
you giving to your business right now be
honest it's great to say 110 percent you
can't go over 100 percent a hundred
percent of the max you're not playing at
your max be honest where are you right
now percentage-wise
I'm curious to find out leave it down
the comments below I'm gonna join in the
discussion I also want to give a quick
shout out to Nasser Lyon thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word I really really
appreciate your support thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso hey believe
nation thank you so much for watching if
you want to learn more about this
subject get a little bit deeper on it
I'm gonna share some extra bonus clips
that I hope you'll enjoy how do you want
to be remembered as a football player as
a person of his last 22 years everything
you've achieved as someone who did what
I achieved what was most important to
you I just want people to see me as a as
a hard-working footballer someone that's
passionate about the game and someone
that every time I stepped on the pitch
I've given everything that I have
because that's that's how I feel
going into games at the end of my career
that's how I look back on it and hope
people will see me because I think over
the years it's been you know my life and
my my career people have obviously
looked at certain other things that have
gone on throughout my career and I think
sometimes that's overshadowed what I've
done on the pitch or what I've achieved
on the pitch and that's as much as I say
that that doesn't hurt me of course it
does you know I'm at the end of the day
I'm a footballer that has played for
some of the biggest clubs in the world
played with some of the best players in
the world played for under the some of
the biggest and best managers and
achieved almost everything in football
and I think of course it hurts when
people not questioning it but think
about other things and to come to the
end of my career now and look back and
say you know I've achieved everything
with every club that I've played for
played for my country 115 times been
runner-up twice World Player of the Year
- two amazing footballers
I'm very proud of that I love how for
this record you had fans actually do
little videos they talked about what
they were brave enough to do in life so
for you what was the moment you realized
you're brave enough to kind of just do
this full-time and just go right after
your passion oh you know I think it's
once I discovered YouTube I mean I had
already been going for it with full
force you know and but I was kind of
wondering if I had what it took to make
it and I was really discouraged at times
cuz everywhere I went I just kept being
told like no you're not good enough like
you you know and I could be really
discouraging and so even though I was
going for it I was kind of like in the
back of my mind just really scared like
am I gonna make it I don't know and and
then when I just finally discovered
YouTube and I put it my first video I
just felt so empowered and so excited
because I was like whoa finally
something's working and that's when I
was like I'm gonna you know I don't know
how this is not gonna work out but I'm
gonna chase this with everything I've
got and that's when I was like boom so
success is not based on genetics it's
not based on how nice this car is it's
not based on how pretty my face is how
small my nose we need to look you know
whether or not I'm the right complexion
I have an 8-inch scar down the side of
my face but I have a camera in front of
me more often than not which just means
that you know if you work hard and your
work is recognized
you know the sky's the limit so all
those people out there think they ugly
and everything i'ma hold it down for you
but more importantly you know you can
still be a success
so all those people that think well I'm
too short well I'm holding down for you
and more importantly you could still be
a success finding the things that are
that you're excited about and that you
can give your all you can work really
hard towards attaining string those days
of efficiency and efficient action
together and success can happen easy